welcome to the huberman Lab podcast
where we discuss science and
science-based tools for everyday
[Music]
life I'm Andrew huberman and I'm a
professor of neurobiology and
Opthalmology at Stanford school of
medicine today we are discussing how to
build tenacity and willpower previous
episodes of The hman Lab podcast have
focused on the topic of motivation and
while motivation and willpower are
linked thematically and mechanistically
today we are going to discuss tenac
that is the willingness to persist under
pressure and resistance of different
kinds and willpower which has to do with
both the motivation to do things and the
motivation to resist certain things
today you will learn about the
Psychology and Neuroscience of tenacity
and willpower and I must tell you this
is a fascinating literature in fact you
will learn about a brain structure that
at least to my knowledge most
neuroscientists are not even aware of
and yet in researching this episode I
absolutely fell in love with this brain
structure because of its incredible
ability to integrate the very sorts of
information from within and from outside
of you to harness and build tenacity and
willpower and indeed today you will
learn research supported tools for how
to enhance your level of tenacity and
willpower in any circumstance before we
begin I'd like to emphasize that this
podcast is separate from my teaching and
research roles at Stanford it is however
part of my desire and effort to bring
zero cost to Consumer information about
science and science related tools to the
general public in keeping with that
theme I'd like to thank the sponsors of
today's podcast our first sponsor is
Maui Nei venison Maui Nei venison is the
most nutrient-dense and delicious red
meat available I've spoken before on
this podcast in Solo episodes and with
guests about the need to get
approximately one gram of highquality
protein per pound of body weight each
day for optimal nutrition now there are
many different ways that one can do that
but a key thing is to make sure that
you're not doing that by ingesting
excessive calories Maui Nei venison has
the highest density of quality protein
per calorie and it achieves that in
delicious things like ground Meats
venison steaks jerky and bone broth I
particularly like the ground venison I
make those into venison burgers probably
five times a week or more I also like
the jerky for its convenience especially
when I'm traveling or I'm especially
busy with work and know that I'm getting
an extremely nutrient-dense high quality
source of protein if you'd like to try
Maui Nei venison you can go to mauii
Venison
docomo and get 20% off your first order
again that's Maui venison
docomond to get 20% off today's episode
is also brought To Us by Helix sleep
Helix sleep makes mattresses and pillows
that are tailored to your unique sleep
needs now sleep is the foundation of
mental health physical health and
performance when we are sleeping well
and enough mental health physical health
and performance all stand to be at their
best one of the key things to getting a
great night's sleep is to make sure that
your mattress is tailored to your unique
sleep needs Helix sleep has a brief
two-minute quiz that if you go to their
website you take that quiz and answer
questions such as do you tend to sleep
on your back your side or your stomach
do you tend to run hot or cold in the
middle of the night maybe you don't know
the answers to those questions and
that's fine at the end of that
two-minute quiz they will match you to a
mattress that's ideal for your sleep
needs I sleep on the dusk DUS us
mattress and when I started sleeping on
a dusk mattress about 2 years ago my
sleep immediately improved so if you're
interested in upgrading your mattress go
to helixsleep.com
huberman take their 2-minute sleep quiz
and they'll match you to a customized
mattress for you and you'll get up to
$350 off any mattress order and two free
pillows again if interested go to
helixsleep.com huberman for up to $350
off and two free pillows okay let's talk
about tenacity and willpower and how to
enhance your level of tenacity and
willpower I will also mention certain
cases we're having too much tenacity and
willpower can be problematic for mental
health and physical health but for most
people I believe that enhancing one's
level of tenacity and willpower would be
advantageous now you'll be relieved to
know that while there are a near
infinite number of different
circumstances where one would need to
draw on tenacity and willpower in order
to succeed there is one major mechanism
within the brain indeed one major
mechanism by which tenacity and willower
are generated and it arrives through the
activation of a particular brain center
that is a hub but that is it lies at the
interface of many other neural circuits
and has input from all the critical
neural circuits that one would need in
order to generate tenacity and willpower
now we are going to return to that
particular neural circuit a little bit
later after we talk about the psychology
of willpower because in talking about
the psychology of willpower it will
frame up as to why understanding this
one particular brain Center or Hub of
inputs and outputs from different neural
structures in the brain and body will
indeed allow you to get the most out of
the tools that have been shown in
scientific research to enhance your
level of tenacity and willpower in other
words understanding the psychology of
tenacity and willpower while valuable if
it's coupled with an understanding of
the underlying neural mechanism and
notice I use the singular neural
mechanism not mechanisms for generating
tenacity and willpower will allow you to
use and to tailor the specific protocols
for enhancing tenacity and willpower to
your unique circumstan es so this is yet
another case where certainly life
circumstances vary from one person to
the next the need for tenacity and
willpower varies tremendously for
instance some people may need more
tenacity and willpower in order to
engage in certain behaviors others of us
might need more tenacity and willpower
in order to resist certain types of
behaviors today you will learn about the
brain Center that governs all of that
and then you can frame it within the
psychological understanding of tenacity
and willpower so that you can get get
the most out of the protocols that we
will discuss let's start by talking
about what tenacity and willpower
clearly are and separating tenacity and
willpower from some other psychological
constructs that they often get confused
with because this will be important in
understanding exactly what we are trying
to build when we say we want to build
tenacity and willpower so tenacity and
willpower can be distinguished from
habit execution habit execution is what
you do anytime you wake up in the
morning maybe you lie there for a bit
maybe get out of bed immediately
hopefully you get outside and get some
sunlight in your eyes especially on
cloudy days go brush your teeth use the
restroom engage with others in your home
if you live with others Etc all of those
sorts of behaviors while on some days
can be a bit more challenging especially
the get out of bed part maybe you didn't
get a great night's sleep the night
before for instance but all of those
sorts of behaviors are behaviors that
you have the neural circuit to generate
and that typically you can generate
without a lot of willpower
required now willpower sometimes also
referred to as tenacity grit or
persistence is a distinctly different
phenomenon than habit execution because
willpower and tenacity require that we
intervene in our own default neural
processes such as habits or particular
patterns of thinking and essentially
govern ourselves to do or not do some
particular thing and that process
requires effort it requires energy and I
think all of us are familiar with that
feeling of effort or energy that's
required in order to engage in a
behavior that we really don't feel like
engaging in or avoiding a behavior or a
thought that by default we would
naturally just engage in and when I talk
about energy in this context I mainly
talking about neural energy remember
that neurons nerve cells in your brain
and body use chemical and electrical
signaling to communicate with one
another that's what allows you and all
of us to do all the things that we do
think feel move Etc
now of course that chemical and
electrical communication requires fuel
sources that indeed come from things
like glucose ketones the creatine
phosphate system multiple fuel systems
feed the energetics of the brain But
ultimately when I talk about energy in
today's discussion I'm talking about the
energy required to engage in or to
resist in a particular behavior and that
level of energy can be quite High
depending on how much resistance we are
feeling internally or externally right
somebody can be telling us you're not
going to be able to do this you can't do
it and you can say no I have a ton of
resolve I have a ton of tenacity
willpower and I'm going to push past all
the barriers that you are setting up for
me on the outside often times all too
often I should say we experience
resistance from the inside where we are
feeling like we don't want to do
something or we really want to do
something and we are having trouble
either engaging in the thing that we
don't want to do or that we know we
should do but we just don't feel that
level of motivation for or we are having
a hard time resisting the thing that's
pulling us toward it so in that context
it's important for us not to just
distinguish tenacity and willpower from
habit execution but also draw out a
Continuum with tenacity and willpower at
their most extreme on one end of that
Continuum and apathy and yes depression
on the other end of that Continuum and
we will return to the topic of
depression a little bit later but I can
just ceue it up right now by saying that
one of the Hallmark features of major
depression is a lack of positive
anticipation about the future that leads
to this is important there's a verb
tense here that leads to a much lower
tendency to engage in the specific types
of behavior that would allow one to
arrive at a particular new different and
positive future so I'm deliberately
putting apathy and depression next to
one another at one end of the Continuum
and I'm putting grit persistence
tenacity and willpower at the other end
of the Continuum and a little bit later
it will be become very clear to you why
I put those particular items on the
Continuum as opposed to other
psychological constructs such as
motivation because it turns out that
motivation is what allows you to move up
and down that Continuum but motivation
itself as a verb is distinct from what
we call tenacity and willpower and
motivation itself is distinct from what
we call apathy and depression but
motivation is the engine or the motor
the verb that allows you to move up and
down that Continuum and today you will
learn multiple tools that will allow you
to move toward the tenacity and
willpower end of that Continuum by
engaging a very specific neural circuit
before we get into the discussion of
neural circuits I'd like to talk about
the psychology of willpower and this is
something that really has been
considered by psychologist for well over
a hundred years William James wrote
about this the ancient Greeks wrote
about this the topic of willpower is
certainly not a new one and yet the
formal study of willpower power in the
laboratory context that is bringing
human subjects into the laboratory and
examining what sorts of conditions allow
them to engage their willpower and
tenacity what sorts of conditions really
sap or drain their willpower and
tenacity and of course parallel
experiments done in what we call
preclinical models which are animal
Studies have revealed to us a lot about
the sorts of conditions that allow us to
generate willpower and the sorts of
conditions that drain our willpower now
if we are to throw our arms around that
entire literature there is a big batch
of that literature not the whole batch
but there's a big batch of that
literature that believed and still
believes that willpower is a limited
resource much like fuel in the body or
fuel in a car now the idea of willpower
as a limited resource is certainly not a
new idea but again the formal study of
willpower and willpower as a limited
resource really dates back a little over
20 25 years when Roy bister and
colleagues started to explore the idea
that of course had been kicked around
for years that with each additional
decision that we have to engage across
the day and with each additional bout of
willpower that we have to draw on as a
resource that we would drain this
reservoir of willpower that we all have
within us now bow meister and colleagues
refer to that process as ego depletion
now when people hear the word ego some
people think Freud ego super ego id and
so forth most people think ego like
somebody having a big personality where
they think a lot of themselves when Bal
Meister referred to Ego depletion he was
defining ego depletion as a concept of
oneself and a concept of outside
challenges and the degree of effort
required to bridge one's concept of self
and those challenges and so ego
depletion is really a operational
construct within the field of psychology
so we don't want to get too distracted
by that word ego there's a tendency
anytime people hear ego if they hear
narcissism or if they hear gaslighting
to immediately assume that they know
what that means when in fact the formal
definitions of those quite often differ
from the way that they're kicked around
on social media the internet and even in
a lot of popular writing about
psychology okay so let's just note that
ego depletion is the term that Bal
Meister used to describe the ability for
our willpower to be depleted with each
successive attempt to engage willpower
and by extension our ability to
replenish our degree of willpower if we
take a break from making decisions and
engaging our willpower but ego depletion
itself isn't the Focus right now the
Focus right now is whether or not indeed
willpower is a limited resource and
whether or not with each decision that
we make and each effort to either engage
in an activity that we prefer not to at
least in that moment and with each
attempt to resist a behavior thought Etc
that is pulling on us or that we feel
that we want to engage in by default
either you know eating the cookie or
thinking the thought or engaging in a
particular type of behavior of any kind
and we need to resist that that it is
draining that willpower resource now
before I go any further I know that some
of you out there are probably aware that
ego depletion and the bow Meister theory
of willpower as a limited resource has
been very contentious especially in
recent years and so today what I'm going
to do is I'm going to first present
present the Bal meister and colleagues
work about willpower as a limited
resource and then I'm going to present
some of the conflicting evidence that
Carol D my colleague at Stanford school
of medicine and researchers elsewhere
have carried out metaanalyses and
entirely new experiments which indeed in
some cases contradict the findings of
Bal Meister but more often than not
contradict the conclusions that Bal
Meister Drew about willpower so if we
are to understand the psychology of
willpower and tenacity it's important
that we understand and the concepts of
ego depletion and willpower as a limited
resource even if after hearing all the
evidence you decide that willower is not
a limited resource and in fact I'm quite
confident that once you hear about the
bow Meister work and then you hear about
the work of DW and others which in some
ways counters the conclusions of bow
Meister that you'll have a much firmer
and certainly much more complete
understanding about what tenacity and
willpower are and perhaps and here I'm
revealing my own leanings when having
examined the totality of the data that
tenac and willpower in some cases is a
limited resource that can be replenished
by engaging particular processes within
the body that's right within the body
but that willpower and tenacity and most
importantly how to engage tenacity and
willpower especially when you have a lot
of challenges in front of you not just
one challenge but multiple challenges
that need to be carried out throughout
the day over weeks over months Etc that
tenacity and willpower can be drawn upon
repeatedly without them being depleted
if you are clear on your beliefs about
tenacity and willpower so I realized
that what I just brought up was a
controversy about something that I
haven't even discussed yet so it might
seem like a bit of a swirl of
information for which there's really no
context but the reason I bring up the
controversy at this stage of our
conversation is that the moment that the
words ego depletion or willpower is a
limited resource falls out of my mouth I
can hear those voices out there saying
wait a second I thought that was all
debunked and I want to make very clear
willpower is a limited resource and ego
depletion have not been debunked it's
simply a controversial area of
psychological research and more
importantly for today's discussion we
have to understand the theory of
willpower as a limited resource if we
are to understand the controversy that
is the counterargument of what willpower
really is that comes from other groups
so I really want to give you both sides
of the story so that when we get to the
underlying neural mechanisms for
tenacity and willpower and we get to the
tools and protocols for increasing your
level of tenacity and willpower and your
flexibility of willpower in different
contexts that you'll be able to get the
most out of those tools and protocols
okay so let's take a look at the
evidence that willpower is a limited
resource I think most of us are familiar
with what willpower feels like that is
what it feels like to be tenacious and
again there are two sides to this coin
there's willpower and tenacity of the
sort of trying to engage in a behavior
when we really don't want to or when our
impulse is not to engage in that
behavior and I say when our impulse is
not to engage in that behavior because
often times we want to engage in the
behavior we want to study we want to
learn the instrument we want to perform
well we want to exercise we want the
benefits of all those things so it's not
that we don't want the outcomes or the
rewards of those things and in many
cases it's not that we don't enjoy those
activities but that for whatever reason
we are feeling a lack of motivation
we're drifting down that Continuum
toward the more apathetic end of things
hopefully not all the way to deep
depression and apathy but we're drifting
that way or we're not far enough up the
Continuum and we're not engaging enough
motivation to feel like the desire to do
something either for its own sake or for
the rewards and outcomes of that thing
are sufficient to allow us to just do
that thing hence the Nike slogan just do
it which is a wonderful slogan except
that in the absence of any understanding
about the mechanisms of how we can get
ourselves to just do something
oftentimes it falls short and to be
honest anytime I hear about people
saying well just eliminate the thinking
and just do it that is valuable advice
until it doesn't work because when it
doesn't work it simply doesn't work and
then you need to rely on other tools and
mechanisms which are the sort that we
will talk about today so while I have
great respect for the just doit Mantra
when it doesn't work it doesn't offer
any alternative solutions to engage
tenacity and willpower and I do not know
anyone on this planet I don't care if
you're David Goggins or Courtney dwalter
there will be days when telling yourself
just do this or just don't do that is
not going to be sufficient for you to
engage in the behaviors or resist the
behaviors or thoughts that you need to
engage in or resist that's just reality
and we should ask ourselves why is that
reality and this is a very important
point and in fact really illustrates the
first bucket of tools and protocols for
increasing tenacity and willpower and
these are the tools and protocols that I
would categorize under the rubric of
modulators I've talked before on this
podcast about the important distinction
between mediators and modulators
mediators are things either
psychological or biological Etc that are
directly in the mechanisms that generate
some sort of action or emotion this
could be neurochemicals like dopamine or
serotonin and so on modulators are
things that can modulate that is can
change our probability of doing
something or not doing something but
they do so indirectly and in the context
of tools and protocols to increase our
level of tenacity and willpower I would
be completely remiss if one of the sets
of tools that is the protocols for
increasing the probability that we can
access high levels of tenacity and
willpower didn't include at least some
of these modulators so I'm just going to
spend about three minutes on these
modulators because what we know for
certain is that the regions of the brain
that generate tenacity and again there
is literally a brainhub for generating
will power and tenacity gets strong
input from the so-called autonomic
nervous system the autonomic nervous
system has two major components they are
referred to as the sympathetic nervous
system and the parasympathetic nervous
system keep in mind because when most
people hear the word sympathetic they
think sympathy they think emotion it has
nothing to do with that simpa means
together and the sympathetic arm of the
autonomic nervous system I know that's a
mouthful is responsible for generating
states of alertness in our brain and
body everything from Panic to being
alert and calm our tendency to move or
our likelihood of moving under pressure
it is also responsible for our ability
to resist movement when we need to
resist movement and therefore it's an
active process so the sympathetic
nervous system is all the things of
action and when it is involved in
generating
inaction those are cases where inaction
requires energy okay I want to be very
clear about this the sympathetic nervous
system isn't just about moving our body
although it has a lot to do with that it
is also responsible for our ability to
resist movement or thought or emotion
when we need to do that clamp down on
ourselves the parasympathetic aspect of
our autonomic nervous system is the one
that sometimes referred to as the rest
and digest neural circuits and chemicals
and that's true but there's a lot more
to the parasympathetic component of the
autonomic nervous system it's also
responsible for falling asleep it's
responsible for us feeling relaxed
it is responsible for most of the states
of Mind and Body in which we are
quiescent where we don't feel an Impulse
to move or when we have a difficult time
getting into action so the sympathetic
and the parasympathetic aspect of the
autonomic nervous system are always in a
push pull with one another think of them
more less on a teeter totter when one
end goes up the other end goes down
they're really in competition with one
another and it's their balance that
reflects how alert or how sleepy we
happen to be now the reason I'm giving
you this rather geeky nerd nomenclature
filled discussion about the autonomic
nervous system in the context of
willpower is that regardless of whether
or not you believe willpower is a
limited or an unlimited resource we know
one thing for sure and that's that
willpower and tenacity ride on our
current autonomic function we can
translate that to Everyday Language by
saying that when we we are well rested
for instance when we've been getting
great sleep of sufficient duration the
previous night and the night before that
our level of tenacity and willpower to
engage in things that we would not
ordinarily engage in by default and our
ability to resist behaviors and thought
patterns that would otherwise be our
default behaviors and thought patterns
is much higher conversely when we are
not getting enough quality sleep on a
regular basis our ability to call on
tenacity and willpower is diminished now
that series of statements I just made is
clearly going to be a duh for most
people but it is very important to
understand that when we are sleep
deprived when we are in physical pain
when we are in emotional pain and or
when we are
distracted when we are thinking about
something else aside from what we are
trying to engage tenacity and willpower
in order to do or not do tenacity and
willpower will be diminished now all of
those things together are just a bigger
duh we all know this if you got a
splinter in your foot it's really hard
to think about not thinking about
something else if you are extremely
hungry or if you had an argument with
somebody that you really care about and
they said something that was
particularly vexing to you and it's
looping around in your head it's going
to be very hard to engage in something
else that you need to do because you're
going to be distracted likewise if
you're sleep deprived likewise if you
are a bit sick or run down or if you're
in any kind of physical or emotional
pain your ability to draw on tenacity
and willpower will be diminished so it's
an absolute truth that your ability to
generate tenacity and willpower rides on
a reservoir of autonomic function and
today we don't really have a way of
quantifying the level of autonomic
function or dysfunction in a very simple
way it's not like resting heart rate
although resting heart rate is involved
for instance if you haven't slept well
for a few nights or if you're
particularly stressed overtrained you
wake up in the morning with a
significantly elevated heart
rate however there is no simple metric
like heart rate or blood pressure or
even cortisol level that can tell you
whether or not your autonomic function
is imbalance that is the sympathetic and
parasympathetic systems of your
autonomic nervous system are in the best
possible balance to generate tenacity
and willpower we don't yet have such a
metric although there are companies that
are starting to develop devices that
hopefully will give us indices of
autonomic function or dysfunction but it
is important that we acknowledge that if
you're not taking care of the
foundational modulators of tenacity and
willpower none of the subsequent tools
and protocols that we will discuss are
going to help you that much over time
you might get tenacity and willpower to
engage one day when you're very sleep
deprived but it's going to be very
difficult to consistently engage
tenacity and willpower for that reason
if you have any struggles with sleep
that is getting enough quality sleep on
a regular basis please see the zero cost
toolkit for sleep that we've put at
hubman lab.com please also see the
perfecty Sleep Mastery sleep episodes
also at huberman lab.com and please also
see the episode with expert guest Dr
Matthew Walker professor of sleep
neuroscience and psychology at
University of California Berkeley we
just revamped the huberman lab website
so if you go to hubman lab.com and you
put something like sleep into the search
function it will take you not just to
the toolkit for sleep but to the exact
time stamps that will queue up
particular topics and protocols around
sleep so if you were to put sleep and
light it would take you to those
particular protocols if you were to put
sleep and magnesium 3 and8 it would take
you to those particular protocols and so
on and so forth okay I don't want to get
too far off topic here during today's
discussion but if you're not sleeping
well and if you're not managing your
stress levels well it's going to be much
harder for you to engage tenacity and
willpower regardless of the tools you
happen to use and those tools could be
everything from behavioral tools to
supplements to prescription drugs you
need to get those foundational mod ators
in check and there are a lot of zeroc
cost ways to do that that are all
spelled out very clearly at the
resources I just described likewise for
stress if you're experiencing challenges
with stress both short-term medium-term
or long-term stress if you think you
have elevated cortisol levels which by
the way may not be the case there are a
lot of tools for modulating stress in
real time increasing your stress
threshold Etc simply go to the hubon
lab.com website and put in stress
threshold tools or stress realtime tools
and you'll get a bunch of zero cost
tools will allow you to do that it's
also worth mentioning that when we get
to our discussion about the Neuroscience
of tenacity and willpower that you will
understand why autonomic health and
autonomic function is so important for
our ability to engage tenacity and
willpower I'll just tell you right now
it's because the neural circuits of the
autonomic nervous system provide direct
and robust input to this Hub in the
brain this brain location that governs
our ability to allocate our mind and
body toward particular activities or to
resist particular activities as many of
you know I've been taking ag1 daily
since 2012 so I'm delighted that they're
sponsoring the podcast ag1 is a vitamin
mineral probiotic drink that's designed
to meet all of your foundational
nutrition needs now of course I try to
get enough servings of vitamins and
minerals through whole food sources that
include vegetables and fruits every day
but often times I simply can't get
enough servings but with ag1 I'm sure to
get enough vitamins and minerals and the
probiotics that I need and it also
contains adaptogens to help buffer
stress simply put I always feel better
when I take ag1 I have more focus and
energy and I sleep better and it also
happens to taste great for all these
reasons whenever I'm asked if you could
take Just One supplement what would it
be I answer ag1 if you'd like to try ag1
go to drink a1.com huberman to claim a
special offer they'll give you five free
travel packs plus a year supply of
vitamin D3 K2 again that's drink a1.com
/ huberman okay so let's think about the
bow Meister data on Willpower as a
limited resource I'm going to briefly
describe one of the first studies that
really said to the field willpower is a
limited resource but I want to be clear
that there are other studies like it and
they all generally follow the same
contour and that General Contour is as
follows bow meister and colleagues and
now many other Laboratories have done
experiments where they bring human
subjects into the laboratory and those
human subjects have to do something that
requires mental effort or energy AKA
willpower the classic example of this is
you bring people into the laboratory
some of them might actually be dieting
or fasted although not always and there
are two platters set out for them one
platter contains radishes just plain
radishes by the way I hate radishes
unless they're pickled radishes I don't
know why that is so these experiments
picked my least favorite vegetable I
love many other vegetables
I disdain the
radish that was just a personal
editorial in any case the radishes are
set out and next to them are freshly
baked cookies and in the room is the
wafting Aromas of freshly baked cookies
so I think it's fair to say that most
people because of a hardwired tendency
to like sugar and fat especially when
they are combined would prefer to eat
the cookies versus the radishes I know
that there are some mutant out there
they're saying I like radishes more than
cookies but look most people like
cookies more than radishes the subjects
in these studies are divided into two
groups one group is told you have to
resist eating the radishes the other
group is told you have to resist eating
the cookies and then the subjects are
observed during this time typically but
this is really not what the experiment
is about per se this stage of the
experiment is really designed to get
people to resist a certain kind of
behavior and the assump assion again
this is an assumption because there's no
brain recordings here no one's in an MRI
machine looking at what brain areas are
activated or not activated there's no
cortisol being measured at least not in
these early
experiments these people are either
resisting something that's pretty easy
to resist radishes or they are being
asked to resist something that for most
people is going to be harder to resist
than resisting radishes which is
resisting freshly baked cookies and that
challenge has been made even more
Difficult by the wafting Aromas of
freshly baked cookies in the room and in
some cases has been made even more
difficult because these people are
dieting and keep in mind that when you
calorie restrict or when you put
yourself on a diet of any kind there is
a wellestablished mechanism in the brain
by which the neurons that engage hunger
especially hunger for fat and sugar and
that respond to things like Aromas and
taste are heightened that is their
activity levels are heightened which
means that things that smell really good
smell really really good when you're
hungry things that ordinarily would
taste really good taste really really
really good when you finally eat them so
the key component of this stage of the
experiment is to engage people's
willpower the second part of the
experiment has all of the subjects
separately engage in another challenging
task and the challenging task that they
are asked to engage in is to solve a
particular puzzle and again different
experiments used different puzzles
different experiments use different
contexts but the original experiments
that b meister and colleagues did had
people try and solve a puzzle that could
not be solved so it's very very
difficult in fact it's impossible but
the subjects weren't aware of that and
then what was measured was how long
subjects persisted in trying to solve
this impossible to solve puzzle
depending on whether or not previously
they had to resist the radishes which is
pretty easy to resist or resist the
cookies which is at least harder to
resist and for some people would be very
very hard to resist now you can probably
already guess what the outcome of this
and similar studies was because it
birthed this entire belief Camp within
the field of psychology that willpower
is a limited resource the outcome was
that if people had to resist the cookies
which is harder to do than resisting the
radishes that they would persist for
less time
when they had to try and solve a puzzle
that unbeknownst to them could not be
solved conversely if people had to
resist something that was pretty easy to
resist such as resisting eating radishes
something that for me would be very very
easy to resist well when they were
subsequently faced with trying to solve
a very difficult indeed impossible to
solve puzzle they persisted much longer
okay so put very simply the study
concluded that if you have to resist one
thing and it's a hard thing to resist
well then you have less air quotes here
resistance in you willpower to engage in
another difficult task subsequently
whereas if you had an easy challenge
just prior or no challenge just prior to
being faced with a challenge such as a
very difficult puzzle well then you had
more resource more willpower to apply to
the solving of that puzzle so the
conclusion that b meister and colleagues
Drew from those results was that
willpower is a limited resource but it
didn't specify nor did they specify
exactly what that limited resource is
and this was quite an attractive Theory
because it jived well with most people's
perception of what willpower and
tenacity was for them this idea that yes
there are things that challenge us both
to do and to resist but that we can do
that but when we are asked to do that
again and again and again while we may
build up some capacity to engage our
willpower and tenacity it and of course
there are those rare individuals that
we've heard about and some of us know
that seem to have just a kind of
bottomless reservoir of willpower and
tenacity most of us have an intuitive
understanding of how hard it is to
constantly be in friction with life to
constantly have to push ourselves to do
things and to resist things and that
while that capacity can expand and grow
and we can get better at it that there
does seem to be something here just
subjectively speaking there does seem to
be something about engaging tenacity and
willpower that yeah it can feel good but
it also requires effort this neural
energy that we were talking about so
that raised the question of okay if
willpower is a limited resource what
exactly is that resource at a
physiological level so balme and
colleagues subsequently went on to
explore what I think is a really
interesting and clever idea frankly I
can't confess that I would have thought
of this but they did they said okay you
know in some cases people are are eating
the cookie and then they're engaging in
this very difficult puzzle in other
cases they're eating the radish and
engaging in this difficult puzzle and of
course other experiments used non-food
challenging choices but they came up
with an idea which was the brain as one
of the most metabolically active organs
in our entire body if not the most
metabolically active organ in our entire
body requires a lot of fuel it requires
a lot of glucose now of course the brain
mainly runs on GL glucose but if you're
following a ketogenic diet your brain
will mainly run on ketones but for most
people who are omnivores or eating
carbohydrates glucose is the main and
preferred fuel source for neurons for
nerve cells in your brain and body for
that matter Bal moister and colleagues
raised the hypothesis that perhaps
glucose availability itself is the
resource that's limiting willpower and
in a whole set of experiments they
really showed that if people are asked
to do a difficult task to engage their
willpower and this could be done by
resisting a particular Behavior or by
engaging in a particular Behavior I'll
just give you an example of engaging in
a particular behavior that requires
willpower or at least focus and mental
energy to contrast it with the resisting
radishes versus resisting cookies
example that I gave earlier one common
practice within experiments like this is
to give people a very long passage of
words so it's a story and then to give
them some sort of rule about how to edit
that passage maybe they have to cross
out every third e or the E that arrive
in the middle of sentences next to
consonants but not other vowels you know
stuff that takes a lot of energy so
these are DOs as opposed to resisting
behaviors like we were talking about
earlier resisting the radish resisting
the cookies although in many of these
experiments there's a command to do
something you know cross out certain
letter E in this passage but also to
resist the reflex to cross out other
ease and of course all this is is under
time pressure and often times it's being
rewarded or scored this is the way that
psychology researchers get people to
engage in particular uh experiments and
behaviors and resist certain things in
the context of a laboratory environment
when those things frankly are kind of
boring and meaningless they'll pay you
more if you do well at the task um
they'll give you money and then subtract
the money that you're going to get at
the end of the experiment if you make
errors and things like that and they'll
do it under time constraint as I
mentioned earlier so there were lots of
different conditions were again here air
quotes draining people's willpower and
tenacity and certainly draining their
mental attention and then they would
have them do another subsequent task so
in many ways this just mirrors the first
cookie radish experiment done by Bal
meister and colleagues but there was an
important intervention put between the
first and the second hard task and that
intervention was to give one group a
glucose beverage of about 150 calories
or so so they would drink a glucose
beverage to increase levels of blood
glucose the preferred fuel source for
the brain versus giving them an
artificially flavored drink or just
water or something that was of course
matched for flavor but that did not
contain any glucose or calories now this
is a clever experimental design if you
think about it because at least at a
first glance the only thing that really
seems to be different is the
availability of glucose for the brain
and you can probably guess what the
outcome of these studies was the outcome
of these studies was that when subjects
are given glucose in between a first
hard task that required willpower and a
second hard task that required willpower
and in some experiments a third hard
task that required willpower that their
levels of willpower were maintained
consistently from one task to the next
and in some cases increased from one
task to the next if they had more
glucose available because they drank
this glucose drink so what's really
interesting and frankly really nice
about these studies is that they attemp
tempted to bridge a psychological
construct like tenacity and willpower
and to test the argument that willpower
is an Expendable resource and yet it's
an Expendable resource that is
replenishable by linking that to a
physiological variable and the
physiological variable they linked it to
was glucose availability in the brain
now this set the field of psychology and
in fact the field of pop psychology that
is the discussion about formal findings
in the field of formal psychological
research Ablaze people were so excited
about this I mean this set of findings
really pointed to the argument that if
you could just keep levels of brain
glucose elevated across your day or at
least stable across the day that you
would have more willpower and tenacity
this thing that humans have been seeking
more of since the beginning of time now
all of that seemed fine and good and in
fact a lot of products and courses were
born out of that literature people were
arguing that you should sip on glucose
drink while doing any kind of hard task
that you should sip on glucose drinks
between tasks that you should be
thinking about literally fuel that you
ingest into your body as fuel for
psychological processes within your
brain that would allow you to perform
better in work in school in athletics
and relationships and all of the domains
of life but of course anytime there is a
prominence or a real excitement about a
particular finding in any field of
science but in particular in Psychology
where it feels so applicable
as did the Bal Meister results you are
going to get other groups that are going
to try and replicate those findings and
that are going to dig into the findings
themselves and look at the statistics
look at how well or poorly powered those
studies were we don't want to get into a
full discussion about powering studies
right now but powering studies has a lot
to do with addressing the question of
whether or not there were enough
subjects in the study to really draw the
conclusion that one Drew or whether or
not the statistics fell out out as yes
there was a significant effect of
glucose ingestion on Willpower and
tenacity but if there weren't enough
subjects well then there are other
variables that could potentially explain
those results so there were a lot of
metaanalyses and other studies trying to
replicate the work of Bal meister and
that's where things got controversial
now we can take a step back from all of
that controversy after all we don't want
to spend too much time on the
controversy itself rather we want to
know what the counter interpretation of
the bow Meister results was and I want
to be very clear there was no real
dispute as to whether or not bow Meister
got the results that he and his
colleagues claimed to have obtained they
did get those results the question
really was about the interpretation is
willpower a limited resource and if it
is is the physiological resource itself
glucose availability to the brain so in
2013 a colleague of mine at Stanford Dr
Carol D and our department of psychology
did a study in which she examined this
idea that willpower is a limited
resource and the idea that the resource
that's limited is glucose availability
for the brain so D and colleagues did an
experiment that in many ways mirrored
the overall organization of the
experiments done by Bow meister and
colleagues there was a difficult task
some cases the difficult task was that
Crossing out of particular ease within a
passage task followed by another
difficult task and the difficult task
that came second was the Stroop task
this is a task I've talked about before
on this podcast although some episodes
ago so those of you that are not
familiar with the STP task the STP task
is where subjects are presented with
words in different colors and they are
instructed to either read the word so to
pay attention to the content of the word
or to the color in which the font of the
word is written this might seem pretty
easy to most of you right if I put up a
card that says apple on it and apple is
written in green you probably wouldn't
have a hard time if you had been
instructed to tell me what color is the
word written in for you to say green
okay but if I I were to hold up a card
that said red but the font is actually
in the color green it's a little bit
harder and if I were to then do that for
a 100 cards or 300 cards and put you
under time pressure where you're losing
money that you're sure to get if you
make mistakes or you will earn money at
the end of the experiment if you get
answers correctly well then you start
making more mistakes that's just the way
these experiments work so they did a
variation on the strep task that isn't
exactly the way I just described it and
the stoop task by the way is one that's
used to probe prefrontal cortex function
this area of our brain right behind our
foreheads that is responsible for many
things but in part is responsible for
context and strategy setting given a
particular set of rules so if you get
onto the bus or get onto the subway
versus walk into a black tie dinner the
context and rules are very very
different as to what you would say or
not say how you would behave how you
would dress your prefrontal cortex is
largely although Al though not entirely
is largely responsible for a lot of the
context setting and Rule setting from
one situation to the next and if you
think about the stre task it's really
just a context dependent strategy task
you either have to pay attention to the
meaning of the words or the colors in
which those words are written and the
number of mistakes that you'll make
depends on how much time pressure you're
under what sorts of neurologic or
psychiatric challenges you might be
facing or not facing so on and so forth
but it's a very robust task that's
existed in the scientific literature for
a long period of time so the D
experiment and by the way there were
actually three experiments in this paper
I won't go through all of them in detail
for sake of time but I will provide a
link to the paper in the show note
captions but the major focus of the
study was to have people engage in one
hard task and then in another hard task
both of which draw on Willpower testing
the idea that willpower is a limited
resource and then providing some of
those subjects with a glucose-rich drink
or other subjects with a drink that was
artificially sweetened so it had no
glucose no calor calories but tasted yes
they match them for taste I know some of
you don't like artificial sweeteners are
saying those don't taste exactly like
real sugar but they managed to match
these drinks for Taste but in one case
the drink would clearly increase blood
glucose in the other case the drink
would not raise blood glucose so the
results of this study are really
spectacular in my mind because what this
study found was that yes indeed
ingesting glucose can improve
performance on these multiple
challenging willpower requiring tasks
however the degree to which the glucose
containing drink could improve
performance depended on whether or not
you believed that willpower was a
limited resource and whether or not you
believed that resource was glucose in
other words if you hear and believe that
willpower is a limited resource well
then indeed with each subsequent task
that you engage in or life event of any
kind that you engage in that requires
willpower and tenacity you will have
less willpower and tenacity to draw on
whereas if you believe that willpower
and tenacity are unlimited and in fact
are divorced from blood glucose as the
physiological source of willpower and
tenacity well then you can engage in one
challenging task and another challenging
task and another challenging task
without any diminishment in performance
now that of course leaves us all in a
very tough position because how are we
to decide what to believe if we know
that willpower can be a limited resource
or willpower cannot be a limited
resource ah well the results of the
direct study and by the way I should
share with you the title of the study
the title of the study not surprisingly
is beliefs about willpower determine the
impact of glucose on self-control and
this was a study published in the
proceedings of the National Academy of
Sciences again I'll provide a link to
this study in the show note captions
there are three major experiments in
this study as I mentioned before I just
gave you the major conclusion of all of
them sort of woven together and if it
wasn't clear already the major
conclusions are that yes ingesting
glucose can improve your ability to
engage tenacity and willpower AKA
self-control from one task to the next
provided that you believe that glucose
is the limiting resource for engaging
tenacity and willpower if you don't
believe that well then you can engage
tenacity and willpower without ingesting
glucose and that's where the
artificially flavored drink comes in
I'll leave it to you to kind of unpack
what that means experimentally but it's
a very clever experimental design that
DW and colleagues came up with because
it argues that yes indeed it's hard to
do a challenging thing right after
another challenging thing but there's no
reason to think that you can't do both
of those things while engaging the
utmost tenacity and willpower if you
believe that tenacity and willpower
exist within you as a single mechanism
that can be harnessed and that it's not
a single mechanism that has a reservoir
that runs down as you engage in one hard
thing thing to the next now this is very
important because we are about to
transition into our discussion of the
physiological that is the neural
underpinnings of tenacity and willpower
which as it turns out is one major set
of brain circuits now there could be
others that are yet to be discovered but
we know that there is one major set of
brain circuits in particular one brain
area believe it or not that an entire
collection of more than two dozen
studies really points to as the seat the
or of what we call tenacity and
willpower but before we transition to
that and the tools and protocols that
that physiological neural understanding
set forth for us to all use and apply
I'd be remiss if I didn't mention that
bow Meister wasn't about to hear these
results from dwen colleagues and just
say Okay willpower is not a limited
resource it's not blood glucose it's all
what you believe about willpower it's
all what you believe about blood
glucose rather BME himself went back to
the lab and did subsequent experiments
that in some ways not all counter the d
results so I'm not trying to confuse
anybody but I wouldn't be doing my job
if I didn't give you both sides of the
story now the good news is that the
tools and protocols that we are going to
arrive at work regardless of which
psychological Camp you happen to be in
the bow Meister camp or the D camp now I
don't want to give the impression that
these are Waring camps and I also don't
want to give the impression that these
are the only two camps of thought and
experimentation within the field of
tenacity and willpower there are many
groups working on these subjects indeed
there have been metaanalyses that have
confirmed the major theories of Bal
meister and there are metaanalyses that
have refuted the major findings of Bal
Meister I will provide links in the show
note captions to a couple examples of
each so that you have those to peruse if
you like but let's discuss for a moment
what B Meister found when they went back
and re- researched I think that's a word
re researched the idea that willpower is
a limited resource and that glucose is
the that limiting
resource balme and colleagues looked at
the D data and said okay fine the data
looked great except for the fact that in
real life and in many previous
experiments that they and others had
done it wasn't just two hard challenges
back toback but often two or three or
four and what Bal meister and others
found was that when subjects are
presented not with just two challenges
back to back but three or more
challenges so back to back to back to
back challenge is that have to engage a
lot of neural energy a lot of willpower
tenacity resistance to do certain things
and effort to engage in certain kinds of
behaviors and cognitive processes that
when subjects had glucose available to
them in the brain by way of ingesting
these glucose drinks sipping those in
between the tasks sometimes even during
the tasks that their performance that is
their willpower and tenacity to engage
in challenges was maintained across
those multiple challenges
and they conceded that one's belief
about willpower could indeed dictate
whether or not willpower was or was not
a limited resource and whether glucose
would or would not enhance one's ability
to engage willpower but they argued that
if one confronts multiple challenging
circumstances as is very naturalistic as
we say it's very typical of everyday
real life then the availability of
glucose during and between tasks the
ability for the brain to engage in its
external environment and take reads of
its internal environment how we feel
inside relative to what's expected of us
was very valuable in allowing people to
engage this thing that psychologically
we describe as tenacity and willpower
I'd like to just take a brief break and
thank one of our sponsors which is
element element is an electrolyte drink
that has everything you need and nothing
you don't that means plenty of salt
sodium magnesium and potassium the so so
called electrolytes and no sugar now
salt magnesium and potassium are
critical to the function of all the
cells in your body in particular to the
function of your nerve cells also called
neurons now people of course have
varying levels of requirements for
sodium so people with hypertension or
prehypertension probably shouldn't
increase their sodium however many
people are surprised to find that by
increasing their sodium intake they are
able to function better cognitively and
physically and that's because a lot of
people especially people who are
following low carbohydrate or even
moderate carbohydrate and really clean
diets often times they're excreting a
lot of water and electrolytes along with
it and simply by increasing their
electrolyte intake using element they
just feel better and function better I
typically drink element first thing in
the morning when I wake up in order to
hydrate my body and make sure I have
enough electrolytes and while I do any
kind of physical training and certainly
I drink element in my water when I'm in
the sauna and after going in the sauna
because that causes quite a lot of
sweating if you'd like to try element
you can go to drink element that's
lm.com huberman to claim a free element
sample pack with your purchase again
that's drink element lnt.com
huberman let's talk about the physiology
of tenasity and willpower and I assure
you that the conversation we are about
to have is not going to be just a bunch
of nomenclature and mechanistic
understanding of the origins of tenacity
and willpower rather it argues that
tenacity and willpower have a unified
source that is a specific set of brain
areas that when active engage that
feeling of tenacity and willpower
regardless of what we are confronted
with regardless of whether or not we are
trying to engage in something that
reflexively we wouldn't otherwise want
to engage in and regardless of whether
or not we are confronted with something
that we have to resist and to me that's
extremely reassuring because whether or
not you believe that blood glucose is
the limiting resource for willpower
whether or not you believe that your
beliefs about willpower and blood
glucose impact your level of willpower
what we know for sure is that there's a
single set of brain circuits indeed
there's a single brain area that seems
to be able to largely if not entirely
explain this phenomenon that we call
tenacity and willpower and that should
be reassuring because what it means is
that tenacity and willpower is the
reflection of a neural circuit function
that is a skill it's an expression of
something that we all have within us we
all have this particular brain area and
quite excitingly this is the third point
this brain area is highly subject to
plasticity there are specific things
that we can do and there are specific
mindsets that we can adopt that allow us
to increase the activity of this
particular brain area indeed to increase
the size of this particular brain area
so that we can call on tenacity and
willpower not just in one circumstance
like school or musical learning or
athletic Endeavors or relationship
Endeavors but rather that we can call on
this brain area in the context of any
and all circumstan ances where willpower
and tenacity are required now we talk
about Neuroscience a lot on this podcast
but it's not often that I point to a
particular brain area and can
confidently say this particular brain
area has an absolutely integral role in
something as kind of highlevel
psychological as tenacity and willpower
but today we can do that and that's
because there's a collection of more
than two dozen studies that point to one
particular brain area and of course its
connections with other brain areas
because no single brain area operates in
isolation every brain area is operating
in the context of neural circuits other
brain areas that it receives inputs from
and gives inputs to and so on but this
one particular brain area really does
seem to underly what we call tenacity
and willpower and we know that through
several lines of evidence first of all
I'll tell you the name of the brain area
although the name itself isn't going to
tell you much unless you're a
neuroscientist or anatomist so I'll give
a little bit of background about it the
name of the brain area is the anterior
mid singulate cortex the anterior mid
singulate cortex is part of a larger
brain area called the singulate cortex
and in humans versus animals it goes by
slightly different names unfortunately
it's just one of the consequences of
different researchers and different Labs
calling the same thing different things
it could be really frustrating but we'll
make it very simple because today we
were referred to this area as the
anterior mid singulate cortex which is a
sub div vision of a larger brain area
simply called the singulate cortex the
anterior mid singulate cortex resides in
the frontal loes so it's behind your
forehead although that doesn't tell you
anything because all of your brain is
behind your forehead if you think about
it and it's about a third of the way
back toward the back of your head and
you actually have two of these
structures two anterior mid singulate
cortices one on each side of the brain
and they receive a lot of inputs from a
lot of different areas and we'll talk
about what those areas are because this
is extremely important when thinking
about the different psychological and
physiological resources that you can
draw upon to engage tenacity and
willpower but for the time being let me
just go through the evidence in kind of
list format of why we feel so confident
that the anterior mid singulate cortex
is such a vital hub for engaging
tenacity and
willpower for each of these points that
I'm about to make there is indeed at
least one if not several quality
reviewed studies in humans so there's a
lot of data from animals both rodents
and primate models Etc that we're not
talking about today but I should mention
all of which supports the human data and
vice versa the data I'm going to
describe now come from humans and from a
variety of different types of studies so
there are a lot of different ways that
one can consider if a brain area is
implicated in a given psychological or
physiological phenomenon like motivation
or sadness or visual perception
and those include for instance if a
brain area is active during a given
phenomenon so one way to explore this is
to put literally wire electrodes down
below the skull record the electric
activity of neurons and assess whether
or not the electrical activity of those
neurons changes when a person is say
viewing faces or feeling a particular
way like feeling tenacious or feeling
bored or feeling aggressive and so on
another way of assessing a particular
brain area's role in a given
physiological or psychological
phenomenon is in individuals where that
particular brain area is injured you
might expect that a particular
phenomenon like willpower like the
ability to perceive faces is present or
absent whether not it's exacerbated or
whether or not it's diminished other
ways of assessing whether or not a given
brain area is involved in a given
phenomenon is whether or not that brain
area literally changes size whether or
not changes in volume over the course of
some sort of training so for instance if
somebody is not able to play a musical
instrument such as myself and then I or
a subject in one of these experiments
learns a musical instrument and the
volume the size of the particular brain
area is assessed across the learning or
simply before and after that musical
learning and it grows or perhaps even if
it shrinks or changes shape one might
determine that it is somehow somehow
involved in the process of learning a
musical instrument you couldn't
unequivocally conclude that but along
with other types of evidence one could
perhaps conclude that so that's just a
partial list of ways to assess brain
area function other ways include
assessing what other areas a given brain
area gets input from so for instance in
the case of the anterior mid singulate
cortex we will soon discuss the fact
that it gets robust input from the
autonomic nervous system which you
already learned about it gets robust
input from reward systems of the brain
such as the dopamine and serotonin based
reward systems of the brain and it gets
robust input from the context and
strategy setting areas of the brain as
well and many other different brain
areas so there's a structural logic as
to why the anterior mid singulate cortex
would be involved in tenacity and
willpower but no single anatomical or
physiological or lesion-based finding is
as compelling as when we consider all of
the results about the anterior mid
singulate cortex together and side by
side so for
instance recordings by neural Imaging of
the anterior mid singul cortex in an
unbiased way meaning people are put into
a brain scanner and brain activity is
examined and mass all of the brain areas
are looked at and people are presented
with either a hard task or an easy task
revealed that the anterior mid singulate
cortex shows elevated levels of activity
in the hard versus the easy task and
again I want to point out that the
researchers were not looking for that
result they simply observed that result
in addition if people who exhibit high
levels of academic performance
across many different subjects are put
into a brain scanner that evaluates
so-called resting state connectivity so
no task but simply levels of activity in
different brain areas that occur
spontaneously so they're just sitting in
the scanner looking at a blank screen
the resting or spontaneous levels of
activity in the anterior mid singulate
cortex of high achieving individuals is
higher relative to those of lower
achieving individuals in addition people
that have lesions or disruptions of
anterior mid singulate cortical function
show increased apathy and depression and
reduced levels of tenacity and
motivation across the board regardless
of what domain of life one is asking
about whether or not it's athletic or
academic Etc indeed successful dieters
show elevated spontaneous and what's
called evoked levels of activity in the
anterior mid singulate cortex so
spontaneous again just at rest they have
higher levels of activity in the
anterior mid singulate cortex
and for those that are presented with
food and they have to resist that food
and they have to resist the smell of
that food and the potential taste of
that food the activity of the anterior
mid singulate cortex goes up even
further especially in those individuals
who can resist that is who can engage
willpower to not eat the delicious food
item conversely individuals that have
failed to exert sufficient willpower to
lose their desired weight and this was
for medical reasons related to trying to
achieve Medical
Health as well as people who are obese
seem to have diminished levels of
activity in the anterior mid singulate
cortex in addition people who are
depressed who Express a lot of apathy
and here we're talking about clinically
diagnosed major depression show reduced
levels of activity in the anterior mid
singulate cortex humans that Express a
lot of what's called learned
helplessness that is they've adopted the
belief and the actions associated with
the belief that no matter what they do
the outcomes are not going to be what
they desire Express lower levels of
neural activity in the anterior mid
singulate cortex so you can see this
list goes on and on but it in fact gets
even more interesting remember earlier I
mentioned that successful dieters have
elevated levels of neural activity in
the anterior mid singulate cortex now
that might seem like a good thing and
indeed it can be a good thing but
there's a pathologic condition
associated with dieting and one's
ability to engage willpower and resist
food and that's in the case of eating
disord such as anorexia nervosa now I've
done a hubman Lab podcast solo episode
about anorexia nervosa and on that
podcast I made the point that I'll make
again now which is that anorexia nervosa
is the most deadly of all the
psychiatric conditions leading to death
in a very large percentage of people
that have it now fortunately there are
treatments and more emerging all the
time but it's a very serious
psychological and physiological
condition that is extremely deadly
individuals with anorexia nervosa
exhibit heightened levels of activity in
their anterior mid singulate cortex both
at rest and when presented with food and
I don't want to go on a full tangent
about anorexia because we covered
anorexia on the previous podcast episode
about anorexia which by the way you can
find at hubman lab.com simply search
anorexia or eating disorders within the
search function but one of the clear
symptoms of anorexia nervosa is that the
reward Pathways of the brain which we
know feed into that is direct
connections to the anterior mid
singulate cortex seem to be activated
under conditions in which people with
anorexia avoid food as opposed to eat
food and then there's a very interesting
and positive literature about so-called
super aers so what we know for sure is
that as people age in particular between
the ages of 60 and 90 there's a
reduction in the size of many brain
areas but the anterior mid singulate
cortex in particular unless certain
things are done to offset that we are
going to talk about what those
particular things are in just a few
minutes but there's a particular
category of humans that's alive now and
that live a very long time these are the
people that stand the greatest chance of
becoming centenarians and many of them
are centenarians so-called superagers
but also within the category of
superagers are people who are 60 years
old or more because not all of them have
reached 80 90 yet and have the cognition
of 40 olds 30y olds and often even of
people in their mid 20s now there are a
lot of things that are different about
these super agers super aers in the
sense that they are maintaining very
youthful levels of cognition but one of
the things that's become very apparent
from the neuroimaging data is that super
agers maintain a volume a size of the
anterior mid singulate cortex that is
significantly greater than their ag-
matched cohorts so the exciting thing is
that there are many many lines of
evidence pointing to the fact that the
anterior mid singulate cortex at least
has something to do with our ability to
generate tenacity and willpower and that
it when active moves us up that
Continuum away from apathy and
depression toward states of being able
to engage in or resist particular types
of behaviors so what I just described as
a bunch of neuroimaging structural
volume data blood uptake data lesion
studies and so on and so forth but we
can simplify all of that and in fact
address something that perhaps I should
have said earlier which is that when
we're talking about tenacity and
willpower we're really talking about one
of two things we are either talking
about that sense within us that has us
saying I will no matter what you tell me
no matter what you put in front of me no
matter what is rolled my way I will
blank now the other expression of
tenacity and willpower
is that within us within you within me
when tenacity and willpower are active
we have that sense within us that
feeling in our body and that thought
pattern AKA feeling in our brain that no
matter what you say no matter what you
do no matter what you put in front of me
I won't so really willpower is either an
expression of I will or I absolutely
will is perhaps a better way to State it
or I absolutely won't now that might
seem like just a simple subjective
reordering of a bunch of physiological
data and psychology studies but it's not
it's actually far more important for us
to understand this I absolutely will and
I absolutely
won't aspect of willpower because if
indeed there is a single brain area that
can govern willpower and willpower is
not one but is at least two things the
sense of I absolutely will no matter
what you say do Etc or I absolutely
won't no matter what you say do Etc well
then this brain area can't be a simple
switch it can't be willpower on Willow
off willpower on Willow off it can't be
absolute as we say it must be graded it
must have levels so it's more like a
slider on a light switch than an on
versus off light switch in addition to
that if there is truly one brain area
that plays a critical role in generating
tenacity and
willpower and tenacity and willpower is
something that it's required from us in
a lot of different contexts where we
have to say I absolutely will yes this I
absolutely won't know that I absolutely
will also yes this etc etc right because
life is complex even just the simple
thing of say dieting or trying to get a
particular degree or trying to navigate
even a simple illness like I'm going to
get through this weak despite feeling
lousy I'm going to take good care of
myself you know all of these things in
some sense require tenacity and
willpower and the behaviors we need to
engage in and avoid engaging in is very
Dynamic depending not just on who we are
and what we're trying to do or not do
but also where we are that day that
moment well that means that the anterior
mid singulate cortex also needs access
to information about context it needs to
understand what's rewarding or
non-rewarding in the cont of what we're
trying to accomplish not just what feels
good in the
moment now fortunately there have been a
number of studies exploring not just the
activity levels of the anterior mid
singulate cortex or the size of the
anterior mid singulate cortex in the
various conditions we talked about
before depression obesity successful
dieters successful students successful
athletes Etc but a lot of anatomical
tracing studies both from fixed that is
from Dead brain tissue so postmortem
brain tissue in humans but also nowadays
they're certain types of neuroimaging
particular something called diffusion
tensor Imaging that allows one to
examine the flow of information in and
out of different brain areas through
so-called white matter tracks tracks
meaning TR r a CTS track so these are
the wires that connect neurons are
called
axons and those axons are in sheathed
with a fatty substance called myelin and
that enement with milin allows them to
transmit information very quickly you'll
see where I'm going with all this in
just a moment
and what we know is that the anterior
mid singulate cortex again of which you
have one on each side of the brain about
a third of the way back from your
forehead to the back of your brain
approximately right above the so-call
Corpus colossum this very robust
collection of white matter tracks that
connects the two sides of the brain well
it gets input and sends input to a
number of different brain areas
including but not limited to the
following autonomic centers that control
for instance cardiovascular f function
increases or decreases in heart rate
respiration how fast and how deeply you
breathe or how shallowly and slowly you
breathe immune system inputs and outputs
with the
spleen not directly but through a couple
of different stations with the very
organs in your body that can release B
cells and t- cells and immune molecules
that can combat bacterial viral and
fungal infections and that can repair
physical wounds and it communicates with
the endocrine system with the systems of
the brain and body that release for
instance estrogen and testosterone which
by the way are present in both males and
females and on a previous episode of The
hubman Lab podcast with Robert spolski
as my guest we talked about for instance
the role of testosterone and many people
think oh testosterone is all about
aggression testosterone is all about
attack testosterone is all about mating
that is completely false while it can be
involved in those different
processes what Dr spolski and I
discussed is that one of the major
functions of testosterone in the brain
is to make effort feel good and you can
see and we'll talk a little bit more
about how that links up very directly
with this concept of tenacity and
willpower so the first point is that the
anterior mid singulate cortex is in
direct communication with all of the
areas of the brain and through a couple
of other stations the body that modulate
our sense of tenacity and willpower
which we talked about earlier the need
for Sleep the need for pain pain or lack
of pain or emotional Comfort or
discomfort to modulate our level of
tenacity and willpower the interior mid
singulate cortex is also directly linked
up with premotor centers these are the
centers of the brain that organize
particular patterns of behavior and
indeed that can suppress particular
patterns of behavior as I tell you that
you're probably filling in the blanks
this is engaging in a behavior or
resisting a behavior the interior mid
singulate cortex is also directly wired
in with the reward Pathways of the brain
it can trigger the release of dopamine
it can also respond to the release of
dopamine and that dopamine release could
be generated behaviorally it could be
generated through some sort of food
reward it could be pharmacologic there
are a number of different ways that the
dopamine system can communicate with the
anterior mid singulate cortex the point
here is that it is in direct
communication with the anterior mid
singulate cortex and the anterior mid
singulate cortex is in direct
communication with the dopamine system
and what I just gave you was frankly
just a partial list of the different
areas of the brain that are
communicating robustly with the anterior
mid singulate cortex it gets information
about interoception our readout of how
we feel in our body it also has robust
inputs and outputs with the areas of the
brain that are associated with
exteroception our perception of what is
out around us so all of that provides a
logical basis for the neuroimaging data
the lesion data the volumetric data that
we talked about a few minutes ago in the
context of depression anxiety high
performance anorexia and so on
but one of the most important arguments
that's ever been made in favor of the
anterior mid singulate cortex being a
major seat for tenacity and willpower
comes from Dr Lisa Feldman Barrett who
is soon to be a guest on the hubman Lab
podcast we've actually recorded that
episode already and it should be out
very soon Lisa's laboratory is well
known for pioneering research on emotion
and affect I strongly encourage you to
listen to that episode once it comes out
and it was actually Lisa herself that
cued me to the importance of the
anterior mid singulate cortex and Lisa
and colleagues have written several
spectacular reviews about the anterior
mid singulate cortex and its role in
tenacity and motivation I will provide
links to a few of those in the show note
captions the one that I'm particularly
excited about the one that I've spent
now an immense amount of time with is
entitled The tenacious brain how the
enter mid singulate cortex contributes
to achieving goals so if you have a
background in biology even if you don't
I think you'll find that review view to
be very interesting and it further
substantiates a lot of the points that I
made a few moments ago about the
different scenarios and types of
individuals that seem to be able to
engage their anterior mid singulate
cortex under different conditions and to
a greater or lesser extent than others
so hats off to Lisa for queuing me to
this incredibly interesting brain
structure I had known that it existed
after all I teach neur Anatomy to
medical students at Stanford and I
taught neuron Anatomy for many many
years but I don't think enough people
and indeed very few professional
neuroscientists could tell you what the
anterior mid singulate cortex does but
it has this apparently incredible
function in generating tenacity and
motivation along those lines one of the
most incredible and important studies
about the anterior mid singulate cortex
and its capacity to generate feelings of
tenacity and willpower comes from one of
my colleagues at Stanford Joe
parvy who essentially went into human
beings who needed brain surgery for
other reasons and stimulated particular
brain areas with a very high degree of
precision the title of the paper that
I'm referring to was published in 2013
in the journal neuron cell Press Journal
excellent journal and it's entitled the
will to persevere induced by electrical
stimulation of the human singulate gyrus
now you'll notice the title said human
singulate gyrus not anterior mid
singulate gyrus but because they had
electrodes and a stimulation technique
that would allow them to stimulate in
very small regions extending as little
as 5 mm but no more away from the
stimulation site they were able to march
their stimulation around different sub
regions of the singulate gyus of humans
while those people were awake and then
asked those people how do you feel what
are you experiencing In This Moment In
addition to that they were recording
various autonomic parameters from those
people so heart rate breathing in
addition to brain wave activity so what
the subjects report when their anterior
mid singulate cortex was stimulated is
that in their words
something was about to happen they felt
as if there was some sort of pressure
upon them from the outside not physical
pressure but that something was about to
happen in fact one of the subjects
described the sensation as it's as if
there's a storm off in the distance but
I know I need to go into the storm and I
know I can make it through the storm
okay another subject described the
experience of having their anterior mid
singulate cortex stimulated as okay
something not necessarily good as going
to happen but I know that I need to
Marshall resources and resist and I'm
confident that I can push through now
because Parisian colleagues are
excellent scientists they of course did
control experiments where they would
tell the person okay we're stimulating
that same brain area that a moment ago
you told me created this feeling of some
pressure upon you that you have to
resist some sense of fight or urgency to
push back but in reality During certain
control conditions they were not
stimulating those brain areas and the
sub objects then reported I don't feel
like anything's about to happen yeah I
don't feel anything at all in other
words it was the stimulation of the
anterior mid singulate cortex and only
the anterior mid singulate cortex that
created the sensation within people that
there was something to resist that there
was something putting pressure on them
again not physical pressure but
psychological pressure and that they
were going to have to Marshall resources
in order to push back upon in fact they
reported feeling as if their body was
getting ready to do something one
subject said something along the lines
of yeah I feel like I'm about to do
something I'm about to go someplace or
do something to resist this foreoing
sense that's now coming over me so this
is very interesting and of course is in
line with all of the data that we
discussed before about neural activity
patterns both spontaneous and evoked
about brain volume changes in the
anterior mid singulate cortex so on and
so forth and it really points to the
idea that the anterior mid singulate
cortex is a hub a hub Hub that receives
information from A diversity of brain
areas that we talked about a few minutes
ago and that generates a particular
sense within us that we are going to be
forward Center of mass that we are going
to resist something and that perhaps we
are going to move or act in some
particular way or as we've been
discussing all along resist action in
some particular way but that it requires
that we Marshall resources which takes
us back of course to the studies of bow
meister and indeed of dck where they
explored willpower as a limited resource
perhaps glucose perhaps as that limited
resource beliefs about willpower and
glucose probably with a high degree of
certainty are going to be involved there
too but regardless of that controversy
it's clear that there's an energy
required there's an activation state of
Engagement or
resistance to a particular Behavior or
thought pattern that we all associate
with this phenomenon of tenacity and
willpower and in a kind of miraculous
way you know as a neuroscientist we're
generally taught nowadays that
individual brain areas don't really
trigger individual functions and
perceptions of the brain there are a few
exceptions to that you know you have a
fusiform face area that really does seem
to be involved in the perception of
faces and when lesion you can't
recognize faces but outside of just a
few limited contexts it's very rare that
one comes across a literature that
across all of the studies involved
point to a single brain structure and
its networks as giving rise to something
as complex and flexible as tenacity and
willpower but in the case of the
anterior mid singulate cortex it really
does seem to meet those criteria as the
brain Hub responsible for tenasity and
willpower now a key idea that Dr Feldman
Barrett has contributed to studies of
the an mid singulate cortex as a
structure that helps us generate what we
call tenacity and willpower to help us
achieve different types of goals
is this idea of
allostasis most of you have perhaps
heard of homeostasis which is the idea
that all of our cells all of our organs
indeed our entire body and psychology
are always seeking homeostasis the
perfect balance of sleep and activity of
food and burning fuels of oxygen and
carbon dioxide and so on and so forth
and while homeostasis certainly exists
and is a valid phenomenon there's also a
concept that we hear far less about but
that is equally important which is the
concept of allostasis allostasis is the
idea that much of what our brain and
body need to do but especially our brain
is to allocate right allostasis to
allocate resources to particular
functions depending on our motivational
goals and the challenges upon us and in
every way what we understand about the
structure and function of the anterior
mid singulate cortex is that it is doing
just that it is deciding how much
glucose should a given brain area
consume perhaps a brain area that's
involved in visual perception because
you're involved in a motivational task
where in order to succeed you need to
pay careful visual attention to
particular things or you're involved in
a task where you have to listen to
particular things or perhaps you are
involved in a physical foot race where
you don't want to allocate a lot of
energy towards thinking about your
stride or your step unless that's
necessary and you actually want to shut
down your brain activity as much as
possible except for the brain areas that
are required to get you to continue run
in that sense the interior mid singulate
cortex as a sort of a dial on how much
fuel is consumed not by the brain and
body as a whole but by individual brain
and body parts meets all the criteria of
what you would want for a brain area
that controls things like tenacity and
willpower because even for those
individuals who seem to just have an
endless supply of tenacity and willpower
they too have to go into habitual
Behavior they can't simply lean into
every aspect of life with the kind of
resistance from outside and the
resistance against those outside forces
or even resistance to internal forces
voices in their head Etc on a constant
basis they still need to sleep they
still need to be functional in that
expression of tenacity and willpower
they need to be able to strategy switch
and they need to be able to come off the
gas as we say not because tenacity and
willpower are necessarily a limited
resource but because for so many aspects
of Life engaging tenacity and willpower
is not advantageous hence the example I
gave earlier about eating disorders
where an apparently hardwired function
of our brain to be able to generate some
sort of reward for resisting a given
Behavior goes too far and then can
actually threaten one's own health or
even life so the concept of allostatic
load allostatic balance and alistic
function is something that we get into
in a fair amount of detail in the
discussion with Dr Feldman Barrett in
that episode which is coming out soon
but in the meantime if you are to think
about the anterior mid singulate cortex
as having a single function the function
that Dr Feldman Barrett has ascribed to
it as controlling how much energy
different brain and body areas should
get in a given context well that makes a
lot of sense to me and I think it's the
one that best describes all of the
functional data indeed includes or jibes
with all the anatomical data about the
anterior mid singulate cortex as well
one of the really important twists in
all of this is that
the anterior mid singulate cortex is not
just sitting there to allocate and Dole
out different amounts of energy and
activation to different brain areas it
is also receiving input from both the
brain and body and in sort of a
beautiful Twist on the whole story of
what the anterior mid singulate cortex
does we know that when we move our body
we are activating the anterior mid
singulate cortex and we know that when
we move our body because we in some way
forced ourselves or encouraged ourselves
to do it we activate the anterior mid
singulate cortex more similarly and
because the Anor mid singulate cortex is
so flexible in the different context in
which it can be
activated if we are simply reading or we
are listening to something that we're
supposed to learn or trying to learn a
piece of music or trying to do anything
for that matter the anterior mid
singulate cortex yes will be activated
but that its levels of activation are
far greater when we experience a lot of
resistance that we have to overcome
remember the earlier result and by the
way I'll provide a link in the show note
captions to this particular study or set
of studies there are about two one
really spectacular one and a couple of
others that um tangentially point to the
same finding that when people engage in
a hard task not an easy task but a hard
task that the anterior mid singulate
cortex activity is elevated so the way
to think about the anterior mid singul
cortex is that it's not just sitting
there as a hub that you have to reach
into and activate it's also receiving
inputs that can activate it and that's
what allows us to now talk about the
tools and protocols that don't just
allow us to engage our anterior mid
singulate cortex and access more
tenacity and willpower but that allow us
to exercise not in necessarily in the
context of physical exercise although it
could be that too but to exercise our
anterior mid singulate cortices ability
to engage not just in that challenging
context but in other challenging
contexts as well in fact I'll just tell
you right now that studies in non-human
primates and to a limited extent in
humans but here we think there's a
strong analog between the non-human
primate data and the human data the
anterior mid singulate cortex is choa
block full of the expression of
molecules such as cyas 2 receptors to
various
neurotropins particular types of nmda
and methylaspartate receptors all of
which if none of those names mean
anything to you just know that all of
them refer to different aspects of and a
capacity for synaptic plasticity which
is the ability for Connections in the
brain to change they can get stronger
you can actually grow new Connections in
other words the anterior mid singulate
cortex can be built up as a structure to
engage tenacity and willpower by
activating it through one or a limited
number of different types of behaviors
meaning engagement in behaviors that
frankly we would rather not engage in as
as well as not engaging in behaviors
that reflexively we really want to that
we're sort of drawn to engage in both of
those contexts the I absolutely will
even though frankly I don't want to or
you're telling me I can't as well as
that I absolutely won't even though
you're tempting me to do that or that's
tempting me to do that or even I'm
tempted to do that that buildup of the
anterior mid singulate cortex has
extensive carryover into other domains
of life because it's the same structure
that is then used for other types of
behaviors and learning that require
tenacity and willpower so that's
incredibly reassuring in fact it's
downright exciting because as I
mentioned earlier while there are a near
infinite number of different
circumstances where we each and all need
tenacity and willpower it seems that
there's a very generic mechanism for
generating tenacity and willpower and
that means that if we can build up our
capacity for tenacity and willpower by
engaging particular types of behaviors
and resisting particular types of
behaviors will then it's going to carry
over in a very functional way to the
other aspects of life that we find
challenging and that we may find
challenging in the future okay so by now
I like to think that I've convinced you
because frankly the data are very
convincing that the anterior mid
singulate cortex is a vital Hub within
your brain for allocating energy and
resources to generating tenacity and
willpower and perhaps it's taking you a
lot of tenacity and willpower to get
this far through the episode waiting
with baited breath presumably to to
learn how exactly you can improve the
functioning of your anterior mid
singulate cortex now fortunately there
are published peer- rreview data that
explain how to do that in fact there's a
study that was published in 2006 by
colum and colleagues entitled aerobic
exercise training increases brain volume
in aging humans and before you go runoff
literally and engage in cardiovascular
exercise I'm just going to describe to
you the Contour of this study and what
specifically was done so that you can
best implement the best protocols for
your particular
circumstances this was a study
exploring why and how certain brain
areas and brain volume generally
decreases as we age it's well known as I
mentioned earlier that individuals aged
really 50 and older and maybe even as
early as 30 and older experience a
decrease in brain volume with particular
brain areas shrinking faster than others
but of course there are other people
that include include the superagers that
we talked about earlier and many many
other people who are not superagers who
don't experience the same decrease in
brain volume so why is it that they
maintain the same brain size that they
did when they were younger or undergo
less decrease in brain size that's what
the researchers for this study were
initially interested in understanding
and they did come to some really
interesting conclusions about that but
they also came to some interesting
conclusions that relate to today's
discussion on tenacity and
willpower this study involved having
individ ual who were 60 to 79 years old
divided into one of two groups one group
did cardiovascular exercise the other
group did more calisthenics SL
stretching type exercise both groups did
one hour of exercise three times per
week the group that did cardiovascular
training initially started off by doing
and by the way they just simply called
it aerobic training but this could be
rowing on the rower this could be
running this could be cycling I think
for sake of understanding application of
tools and protocols you would want to
pick any kind of activity that you could
do consistently without injuring
yourself that's what's really important
and that gets your heart rate elevated
they started off these
individuals with relatively low
intensity cardiovascular exercise for
that hour getting their heart rate up to
about 50% of their maximum heart rate
but very quickly had those individuals
increase the intensity of those
cardiovascular training sessions so they
were doing again three 1 hour sessions
per week getting their heart rate up to
about
75% of their maximum heart rate
sometimes a little less 60% sometimes a
little bit more but in that General
range so for those of you that think
about different zones of cardio this is
probably in the area of zone three not
quite Zone 2 cardio maybe zone three
cardio so where one can not carry out a
conversation very easily but where one
is not completely gasping for air as one
would if they went to their maximum
heart rate or near maximum heart rate
okay so three 1hour episodes of
cardiovascular training per week at a
moderately high intensity the other
group simply doing calisthenics and
stretching for the equivalent amount of
time and they had another group within
the study that were much younger that
did similar activities or no activity
simply as a control for the brain
Imaging data now I'm summarizing the
study with a fairly broad brush both for
sake of time and of course I'll provide
a link to the study in the show note
caption so you can access it and impres
in more detail if you like but I
wouldn't be talking about this study if
it were simply a study about
cardiovascular training and brain volume
I'm talking about this study because the
specific brain areas that maintained or
in some cases increased in volume as a
consequence of doing these three hours
per week of moderate intensity
cardiovascular training included of
course the anterior mid singulate cortex
that was actually the primary location
in which the maintenance of brain brain
volume was observed and in some cases
increases in brain volume were observed
right this is a group of people who
normally would be
losing volume size of their anterior mid
singulate cortex but for which 3 hours a
week of moderate intensity
cardiovascular training maintained the
volume the size of that anterior mid
singulate cortex and in some cases
increased the volume the size of
anterior mid singulate cortex and they
also observed a maintenance or increase
in the size of the anterior white m
matter tracks remember t r a c TS I
didn't spell that out before just to
spell it out for fun although that is
the sort of thing that I would probably
do those white matter tracks are the
communication routes by which different
brain areas communicate and this
anterior white matter tract that
maintained size in the people that did
cardiovascular training as compared to
those that simply did the calisthenics
training and stretching is the very
white matter tracks that connects the
two sides of the brain the frontal l
that allows the anterior mid singulate
cortex on one side of the brain and the
anterior mid singulate cortex on the
other side of the brain as well as other
brain structures to communicate with one
another so this is really spectacular I
mean the authors of the study didn't
embark on the study to find or even look
for increases or maintenance in the
volume of the anterior mid singulate
cortex and the communication routes in
and out of the anterior M singulate
cortex it just so happened that
cardiovascular training done three times
per week for an hour at a time at modern
intensity increased the size of the
anterior mid singulate cortex and as I
mentioned the white matter tracks which
allow information to go in and out of
the an mid singulate cortex now we
should all be asking ourselves why would
that be the case I mean somebody gets on
a stationary bike and pedals or goes out
on a road bike or runs is there
something inherent to running or cycling
or rowing or swimming or an aerobics
class dancing Etc that gets the heart
rate up that directly feeds into the ENT
mid singulate cortex after all is the
anter mid singul cortex responsible for
generating the activity of running or
cycling or swimming no rather the
interpretation is that in order to
engage in this one hour three times per
week set of sessions of cardiovascular
training they had to allocate resources
they had to get up out of a chair they
had to get off the couch they had to say
no to other potential obligations social
engagements meals Etc and get to these
exercise classes or sessions that they
did with others or alone now an
interesting and in fact important aspect
of the study is that the compliance with
this three hours per week of
cardiovascular training was very high
85% of individuals engaged in these
sessions across the six-month period of
the study I should have mentioned that
earlier the study was carried out over
the course of six months they did not
have the opportunity to do neuroimaging
after say a week or two weeks so they
image these people's brains before and
they image these people's brains after
this six-month period it's anybody's
guess as to whether or not they would
have observed the same or maybe even
greater increases at the one month
interval Etc we simply don't know
there's a great cost both energetic and
financial to doing these kinds of
studies so they looked at a six-month
period but setting all of that aside
this is a very important study in the
context of today's discussion because
what it means is that if we acknowledge
that the anterior mid singulate cortex
and the volume of an mid singulate
cortex is related to one's ability to
generate tenacity and will power for any
number of different
Endeavors well then having access to a
tool or a protocol that can increase the
size of one's anterior mid singulate
cortex is going to be extremely valuable
so what's the takeaway from this study
the takeaway from the study is not
necessarily that you should be doing
three one-hour bouts of cardiovascular
training per week for six months to
maintain or increase the size of your
anterior mid singulate cortex I do think
that's the case if you're not already
doing sufficient amounts of
cardiovascular training and what
constitutes sufficient amounts well I
think there's General agreement now both
between the material that I've covered
in our foundational Fitness protocol and
in the series on exercise physiology
with Dr Andy Galpin and in various
discussions with Dr Peter AA the general
agreement is that everyone should be
getting somewhere between 150 to 200
minutes of so-called Zone 2 low
intensity cardiovascular exercise per
week but the results of this study
really point to the idea that we should
all be doing perhaps hours but certainly
we should all be doing some form of
physical exercise but for any of us that
are interested in increasing tenacity
and willpower across domains both for
cognitive and physical Endeavors
emotional Endeavors too for that matter
that we should be engaging in some
exercise and again we're going to talk
about cognitive exercise in a moment but
that we should be engaging in some
exercise that we are not already doing
now that of course will lead many people
to think wait I'm already doing two 100
minutes per week of Zone 2 cardio how
can I add 3 hours more of cardio that's
not what I'm saying what's important to
understand about this whole discussion
about tenacity and willpower is that the
ability to engage the anterior mid
singulate cortex and to build up its
volume literally and increase its
activity relies on one critical feature
which is that you have to be in some
degree of resistance some lack of Desire
or I should say lack of reflexive desire
or ability to engage in that behavior
okay this is super important if you're
thinking about tools and protocols to
increase your level of tenacity and
willpower if for instance you love cold
showers and Ice baths well then it's
very unlikely that taking cold showers
or getting into an ice bath is going to
increase your level of tenacity and
willpower further it might reinforce the
tenacity and willpower that you've
already built but it's not going to
increase it further you need to add
something or subtract something that
makes it harder not easier to engage in
or resist a behavior okay I want to be
really clear about this in the study
that I just described from col and
colleagues they took individuals that
were not exercising prior to the study
and those people had to therefore
generate significant amounts of
motivation in order to regularly engage
in these three one hour per week
episodes of cardiovascular training okay
now the fact that there was no
comparable increase in the volume of the
anterior mid singulate cortex or
anterior white matter tracks in the
group that did the calisthenics and
stretching is also important because it
implies that activities that are easier
to carry out that don't get the heart
rate elevated as much are not going to
create changes in this brain structure
that is associated with tenacity and
willpower and there's a nice
confirmation of that in the study in
fact because they observed as one would
expect a significant increase in V2 Max
in the individuals that were assigned to
the group that did cardiovascular
training but they did not observe a
significant increase in V2 Max in the
individuals that did three 1 hour per
week sessions of calisthetics and
stretching across the six-month period
okay so the important Point here is if
you're already doing let's say an hour a
week of moderate to high-intensity
cardiovascular training or resistance
training for that matter you're going to
need to add something in order to get
further activation of this brain hub for
tenacity and willpower and of course the
idea here or else we wouldn't be talking
about it is that that activation and
that increase in volume in the an mid
singulate cortex would then be
applicable to other endeavors for
instance academics or some aspect of
your professional life or relationship
life that you can build up tenacity and
willpower as a capacity within you or we
should say within your anterior mid
singulate cortices but that the route to
activating and increasing the robustness
of your anterior mid singulate cortex
requires that you engage in something
that you don't really want to do and
certainly not something that you're
regularly engaging in already remember
way back at the beginning of today's
episode we compared willpower and
tenacity to Habit execution right well
this is a simple case where if you're
already doing something simply
continuing to do it might maintain what
you've already got but it's not going to
further build up your tenacity and
willpower so along those lines I don't
want you to Simply take the three 1hour
cardiovascular sessions per week
protocol that they use within the study
and expect it to increase your levels of
tenacity and willpower unless of course
your Curr only doing 1 hour of
cardiovascular training at moderate to
high intensity per week in which case
increasing to two hours may very well
increase your interior mid singlet
cortex and overall level of tenacity and
willpower and certainly doing three
hours per week would be expected to do
it even further and I should mention
that we can extrapolate from this study
in a meaningful way I think in a
grounded way that's related to mechanism
and say well if you for instance like me
can't play a musical instrument or are
not bilingual in language that taking on
the challenge if indeed it's a challenge
and for me it would be a challenge
perhaps for you as well to learn an
instrument as an adult or to learn a
second or maybe a third language if
that's challenging and in fact that's
something that you're resisting doing
well then great it's going to provide an
even greater opportunity to engage the
activity of the anterior mid singulate
cortex remember that study that showed
that hard tasks hard challenges are what
activate the entor mid singulate cortex
easy challenges don't okay habits that
are reflexive simply do not so you have
to pick something hard you have to pick
something that's either physically and
or psychologically hard and of course we
want to highlight the fact that you
never want to engage in anything
physical or cognitive emotional or
otherwise that is psychologically or
physically damaging to you right because
this is something that you're going to
want to maintain or carry out for some
period of time now alone those lines we
could imagine a huge number of different
protocols that one could engage in but I
think there are a couple of key things
that extend across all of those
opportunities first of all it's clear
now based on our understanding of the
anatomical inputs to the anterior mid
singulate cortex that while exercise is
great and certainly movement of the body
when we don't want to move our body AKA
running AKA weightlifting AKA learning a
new skill like dancing or gymnastics or
something of that sort is going to
engage this hub for tenacity and
willpower the an mid singulate cortex
but there are a number of other
opportunities to do that and we can
think of those in a kind of playful
context but one that is both playful and
highly functional and applicable so for
instance if you already resistance train
and you're doing what we now generally
agree as a field is the minimum of six
hard working sets per muscle group per
week in order to maintain or build
muscle size and strength some of you
don't want to build muscle size but
everyone should be trying to maintain
muscle strength there's a very high
correlation we now know between muscle
strength and cognitive function
especially as one gets past 40 years of
age but even younger so maintaining
neuromuscular function and strength is
very very important even if you don't
want to increased muscle size you can
learn how to do that by the way we have
zeroc cost protocols they're all listed
out by going to hubin lab.com check out
the series I did with Dr Andy Galpin
check out the key toolkit takeaways from
that series also available at hubn
lab.com just put exerc
protocols into the search function but
let's say you're already resistance
training you're already doing
cardiovascular training what can you do
to build up your tenacity and willpower
for application in not just that
endeavor but other endeavors well pick
something that you don't want to do
these are what I call in a very
non-scientific way micro sucks these
things suck but they suck a little bit
and they're safe right you have to pick
things that are safe for you but they
suck enough that they require some
effort they require getting over some
friction engaging in something that you
don't reflexively want to do so for
instance that might be one extra set at
the end of a round of three to five sets
of a given
exercise or it could be for instance 100
jumping jacks at the end of what you
consider a hard run it could be for
instance finishing out that language
lesson and then deciding to do five
minutes of sitting still thinking about
the material that you learned when you
so desperately want to just jump on your
phone right pick circumstances where the
degree of resistance is very high where
the degree of impulse to do something
else than the thing that you know you
need to do is very high and then start
applying those on a regular basis it
could be after every workout it could be
in the middle of the workout for
instance some people have a really hard
time not looking at their phone during a
workout I like to listen to podcasts or
music during a workout but I really try
and resist text messaging and reading
email and things of that sort while
working out so the harder that becomes
the more I think about it and the more I
resist it the more presumably activation
of the anid singulate cortex I'm getting
and that you would get as well so these
little micro sucks like ah it sucks not
to look at the phone right now it sucks
to do 100 jumping jacks at the end of a
run of course if you're excited to to
the 100 jumping jacks at the end of The
Run that's not going to be a good Avenue
into activating and increasing the
volume of your anterior mid singulate
cortex everything we've talked about up
until now supports the statement I just
made easy tasks desirable tasks don't do
it it's the thing you don't want to do
so imparting these little micro sucks
can be very useful you'll have to think
about what particular micro sucks you
incorporate into your exercise routines
your cognitive routines and your daily
routines and how often I don't think you
need to go completely berserk on this
doing them all day long but keep in mind
that these are the sorts of behaviors
and resistance of behaviors because
again certain micro sucks might be you
know if you're somebody who practices
intermittent fasting you know we don't
want to send you into the realm of
eating disorder but you know maybe you
really do wait an extra 15 minutes
before your usual first meal time which
for me would really suck that might even
move from micro suck into macro suck
because I like to eat when I'm hungry
but waiting a few extra minutes for no
other reason than allowing oneself to
activate that anterior mid singulate
cortex
circuitry would be one way to try and
build up one's tenacity and willpower so
at some level they should all seem
pretty logical it actually doesn't even
require a firm understanding of the L
Neuroscience for it to of make sense
right you want to do something you
resist doing it that's building up
tenacity and willpower you don't really
want to do something you do it that's
building up tenacity and willpower well
I do believe in fact there a lot of data
to support the fact that our
understanding of the mechanisms
underneath things like tenacity and
willpower can be very advantageous when
trying to carry out these different
types of behaviors to increase tenacity
and willpower why well today we learned
that that there's a huge variety of
contexts in which one can activate the
ENT mid singulate cortex which means
that it's not cardiovascular exercise
per se it's not resisting the cookie per
se right it's not waiting 15 more
minutes to eat or making sure that you
sit still and don't look at your phone
at the end of a learning bout and really
think about what you learned a little
bit more even though it really really
sucks to do that it's really hard it
creates a lot of agitation it's not
about any one of those protocols if you
will per se rather it's about deliberate
engagement in the behaviors that we
least want to do in a given moment or if
you're trying to build up willpower and
tenacity to not engage in certain types
of behaviors it's about our ability to
suppress behavioral action now I do want
to highlight the potential hazards of
this type of approach to building up
tenacity and willpower and indeed to
life and we can call on the earlier
example of Eating Disorders as a very
safe alient one right there is a way in
which all of this can run a muck and we
can get so heavily into stoicism we can
get so heavily into the idea of building
up tenacity and willpower that it takes
us into Realms that are unhealthy for us
psychologically emotionally Andor
physically and that's certainly not the
goal here and I certainly don't want to
motivate that type of behavior or
resistance of behavior we should all be
seeking a relationship with life and
with goals Etc that involves yes I
believe some degree of activating
tenacity and willpower really finding
that fight within us that Parisian
colleagues found when they stimulated
the anterior mid singulate cortex of
people right all of a sudden they're
like yep I'm driving into a storm or
there's something about to happen and
I'm going to have to resist I'm either
going to have to do something or resist
doing something but there's something
activated inside of me I think it's very
important that we are all able to Garner
those resources and to activate those
States within us voluntarily but I also
know from experience and from observing
others and indeed from the literature on
the anterior mid singulate cortex as it
relates to eating disorders and other
aspects of neurologic and psychiatric
challenges is that we also need to learn
how to turn that off with that said the
little micro sucks that we discussed you
know the addition of 100 jumping jacks
at the end of a cardiovascular training
session when you would much rather just
shower up and go home getting into the
cold shower or cold plunge when you
absolutely don't want to do it well
provided you can do it safely that's
going to be the best time to do it if
your goal is to build up tenacity and
willpower to say nothing else of the
known benefits of things like deliberate
cold exposure and exercise like jumping
jacks Etc there are also entire
Landscapes of life and academics and
sport that afford US the opportunity to
build up tenacity and willpower I for
instance can recall taking my so-called
qualifying exams in graduate school
where they ask you questions until you
say I don't know until you don't know
the answer it's just like that puzzle in
the bow Meister study they're taking you
to the point where you basically can't
win and that turns out to be a very
important lesson that extends beyond the
information that they're asking you
about and of course every student at the
end of their qualifying exam runs off
and figures out the answer to the
question that they couldn't get the
right answer to sometimes there is a
right answer sometimes they not if the
committee is pretty diabolical they'll
give you an impossible to answer
question because there's no answer but
the point being that whether or not it's
in martial arts whether or not it's in
sports whether or not it's in music
whether or not it's in academics whether
or not it's in relating to others there
is some value to getting to that point
where you can't solve the puzzle and I
think that's an important message for us
to understand and maybe to incorporate
into our tools and protocols that there
are some Endeavors that have no end
point right there's no winning there's
no Finish Line and those type of
Endeavors are extremely important
extremely important for continually
building up our tenacity and willpower
so much so that we can even take a
somewhat 3,000 mile view from the top
down onto everything we've talked about
today and think about those
superagers those superagers that somehow
are able to maintain the cognitive
function of a much younger person and if
you look at the Daton super agers and
people similar to them you'll find are
always engaged in some activity that's
hard for them they're always trying to
learn something and they have a sort of
playfulness about it but they seek out
those friction points both resistance of
certain behaviors right trying to not do
certain things but perhaps more often
doing certain things learning learning a
new skill learning Pottery learning
music placing themselves into novel
environments that are a little
uncomfortable or a lot uncomfortable
provided that it's safe so from that
standpoint one could even entertain the
idea that because these people are
living much longer than everybody else
in addition to maintaining the cognitive
function of much younger individuals
that perhaps the inter mid singulate
cortex in its ability to allocate
resources to different parts of our
brain and body to meet C certain
motivational goals is actually
associated with this thing that we call
the will to live now the concept of the
will to live is certainly getting a
little bit squishy for scientists like
me who yes I'm happy to entertain
discussions that relate to psychological
constructs such as tenacity and
willpower but as you've probably noticed
I'm very comfortable with and very
excited about the idea that okay maybe
it's relate somehow to brain energetics
and glucose maybe not certainly I'm on
board the idea that belief impact our
physiology and Physiology impacts our
beliefs I'll Dr Ali Crum who was a guest
on this podcast previously talked about
belief and mindset effects which are
very powerful they change our physiology
literally and the D data that we talked
about today but of course also that
there are brain areas and circuits that
underly these things that we call
tenacity and willpower so when we get
into a discussion about tenacity and
willpower and then find ourselves as we
are now talking about the will to live I
don't think it's going too far to say
that when one looks looks at the data on
longevity both physical and
psychological longevity it's very clear
that there are underlying physiological
explanations not the least of which is
likely to be the maintenance if not
growth over the lifespan of this
anterior mid singulate cortex but also
that the people that are achieving that
are continually forging in their
environment they're continually looking
for new environments they're continually
exploring they are not becoming
complacent they are not becoming
sedentary they not existing down at that
end of the Continuum that we call apathy
and depression but that they're not
existing down there and they are
existing up toward the end of the
Continuum that we call tenacity and
willpower and engaging motivation to get
there okay motivation again as a verb
but in doing that that they're
reinforcing the very circuits that give
rise to tenacity and willpower this is
what in engineering terms is referred to
as a closed loop it's like you do a
which leads to B which leads to C which
feeds back onto a and makes a that much
more likely to occur it's like turning
the little a into a capital A and then
turning into a bold face Capital
underline a you know the buildup of
neural circuits so while today we
focused a lot on an individual brain
area anterior mid singulate cortex and
in many ways I presented it as if it's
the Beall end all of tenacity and
willpower it is not the Beall end all of
tenacity and willpower it's our ability
to engage the anterior mid singulate
cortex that allows us to express
tenacity and willpower but in this
closed loop fashion it's our ability to
express tenacity and willpower that then
feeds back onto that circuit and makes
it more robust and more likely to be
accessible in the future when we
encounter something that we don't want
to do or that we have to resist very
strongly in order to not engage in some
sort of behavior or thought pattern so
the big takeaway is that if you want to
increase your tenacity and willpower you
absolutely can you can do that by
triggering activation of this incred
inedible Hub within the brain the
anterior mid singulate cortex for which
there is now a very large amount of
evidence is at least Central to the
whole process of generating tenacity and
willpower the I absolutely will do that
and the no I absolutely won't do that
it's the resistance Hub it's the thing
that's allocating resources to do the
thing that we don't want to do or that
someone's trying to prevent us from
doing it's also the brain area that's
allowing us to resist doing the thing
that we want to do or that someone else
wants to do when we decide that's not
good for us we can really be certain
based on the psychology literature based
on the Neuroscience literature and
really based on this beautiful
literature that's now emerging that
includes the colum study but some other
studies as well that perhaps we'll talk
about in a future episode that we really
can build up our capacity for tenacity
and willpower it's a real thing and as a
final point to this and indeed as a
final protocol I was very excited to
look into the early release of
peer-reviewed papers out from neuron
just this last week and to see that
there was a study albeit in a
pre-clinical model in an animal model
that explored what is called stress
relief as a natural resilience mechanism
and I won't go into the study in full
detail especially not now laid into a
slightly long episode such as this one
but what the study showed is that when
an animal is in a state of despair or
aidonia lack of pleasure when it's under
stress
and then that stress is removed there's
a sense of reward there's a sense of of
well-being that accompanies that release
of stress and that's pretty obvious
that's something that we've known about
for a very long time but what's
interesting about this study and they
actually talk about this in terms of its
applicability potentially to humans is
that when we are able to withstand a
stress maybe that stresses school maybe
that stresses a particular relationship
again you never want to do these things
in a way that's unhealthy or dangerous
but when we are able to do that the
relief that we feel afterwards is its
own form of reward that serves to
reinforce that whole process of tenacity
and willpower that got us through the
stressor and an interesting thing about
this study is that they went on to
compound that reward they showed that
rewarding oneself for having gotten
through a stressful episode actually
serves to increase the capacity to get
through stressful episodes in the future
in other words if you decide to develop
certain tools and protocols to increase
your levels of tenacity and willpower
which frankly I hope that you will at
least consider again provided you do it
safely this seems like a very good thing
to do for all of us especially as we age
and guess what we're all aging from the
time we're
born if you decide to do that pick
something that's challenging overcome
that challenge again this could be the
requirement to engage in a particular
behavior when you don't want to or to
resist a particular behavior that you
would otherwise want to engage in but
also when you've successfully completed
that resistance when you've engaged that
tenacity and willpower and you've
activated that anterior mid singulate
cortex well then occasionally not always
but occasionally providing yourself with
a reward of something that you like and
here it's highly subjective you'll just
have to pick something that you like
again something that's hopefully Health
promoting not Health diminishing can
serve to further reinforce the behavior
that you just engaged in which was to
increase your tenacity and willpower and
if you listen to the episodes that I've
done on dopamine motivation and drive or
on dopamine more generally you will know
that I am not a fan of rewarding oneself
for wins or for engaging tenacity or
willpower for that matter on a regular
basis or certainly every time this is
the sort of thing that just randomly
every once in a while when you've done
the hard thing or if you've resisted the
thing that was pulling on you that you
should reward yourself but of course
reward yourself in healthy and safe ways
for those of you that are interested in
learning more about how to reward the
actions of tenacity and willpower I'll
provide a link to the recently published
paper in neuron in the show note
captions I will also be doing a toolkit
episode that relates to what we covered
today as well as some additional tools
gleaned from other papers and resources
in the not too dist future thank you for
joining me for today's discussion all
about tenacity and willpower we talked
about the idea gleaned from research in
the field of psychology that tenacity
and willpower are limited resources and
that perhaps again perhaps they relate
to this concept of ego depletion that
relates to this idea that what is
depleted or what's limited in our
ability to engage tenacity and willpower
somehow relates to brain energetics and
fuel consumption namely glucose I also
talked about the conflicting data that
argues that if we believe tenacity and
willp power are limited and that glucose
is the thing that limits them well then
that's exactly what happens so I talked
about that controversy and some of the
data that actually reconcile a bit of
the differences there so in the absence
of new data you'll have to decide for
yourself what you believe about tenacity
and willpower however it's very
important to acknowledge the universal
truth which is that our tenacity and
willpower rides on the tide of autonomic
function that is when we are sleep
deprived when we are in pain when we are
in emotional pain or when we are
distracted our tenacity and willpower is
diminished which
calls upon all of us to make sure that
we're taking care of our autonomic
functions through viewing morning
sunlight getting sufficient sleep
adequate nutrition social connections
things that I've covered extensively on
previous episodes then we talked about
the neural underpinnings of tenacity and
willpower and this absolutely incredible
brain structure that we'll call a hub
because it's not operating in isolation
but rather it's getting inputs from lots
of different brain areas related to
reward executive function autonomic
function motor planning goal seeking Etc
that we call the anterior mid singular
cortex this phenomenally interesting
brain area that seems to be able to
generate this thing that we call
tenacity and willpower and that when we
engage or Express tenacity and willpower
by doing the thing that we least want to
do by not doing the thing that we most
want to do in a given moment that we
actually can build up our anterior mid
singulate cortex and thereby build up
our future capacity to engage the enter
mid singulate cortex when we need to
call on tenacity and will power and then
we talked about some of the peer- review
data that shows how that actually can be
done where these individuals who were
not previously exercising did a
challenging three 1hour sessions per
week of cardiovascular training and
indeed their anterior mid singulate
cortex and the connections two and away
from it increased in a way that set them
apart from their age related cohorts
that is their brains stayed younger
maybe even got younger whereas those
that did not do the hard thing right
that didn't engage tenacity and
willpower did not experience the same
effect and then we talked about how
those data could be extended into a
number of different Realms such as
cognitive learning learning languages
learning math learning art learning any
number of different things or in the
Physical Realm engaging in certain types
of exercise that one is not already
engaging in adding in a little bit of
additional exercise specifically at a
time in which you least want to do that
or extending your fasting period if
that's something that you're doing and
that you can do
healthfully simply because it allows you
to exercise your anterior mid singulate
cortex AKA tenacity and willpower and of
course we highlighted that all of that
needs to be done in the context of
psychological and physical safety we
don't want anyone to do things that are
going to be physically damaging to
themselves but if one simply takes the
stance of okay what's something that I
can do in a moment that will allow me to
build up tenacity and willpower well
it's going to be the thing that I least
want to do in that moment or the thing
that I least want to resist doing in
that moment to periodically add in those
little what I referred to as micros
sucks a very um non-scientific frankly
non- psychological term but I think we
all understand what it means little
things that we don't want to do but that
if we do them you can be sure that you
are activating the interent mid
singulate cortex and thereby increasing
the probability the likelihood that you
can access tenacity and willpower more
readily in the future so what I've done
today is explain the scientific studies
in the realm of Psychology and
Neuroscience that explain what tenacity
and willpower are and what allows us to
build up our tenacity and willpower over
time and then it's really up to all of
us to you and to me and everybody else
to figure out in which particular
domains and with which frequency we're
going to decide to build up our tenacity
and willpower so it's clear that
tenacity and willpower are not just
resources that we need to call upon from
time to time in order to overcome things
but then indeed calling on our ability
and building up our ability for tenacity
and willpower can allow us much richer
enjoyment of life and perhaps can even
extend our life by engaging the will to
live thank you for joining me for
today's discussion about the science of
tenacity and willpower and tools and
protocols to increase one's ability to
access tenacity and willpower if you're
learning from and or enjoying this
podcast please subscribe to our YouTube
channel that's a terrific zeroc cost way
to support us in addition please
subscribe to the podcast on both Spotify
and apple and on both Spotify and apple
you can leave us up to a five-star
review if you have questions for me or
comments about the podcast or topics or
guests that you'd like me to cover on
the hubman Lab podcast please put those
in the comment section on YouTube I do
read all the comments in addition please
check out the sponsors mentioned at the
beginning and throughout today's episode
that's the best way to support this
podcast not on today's episode but on
many previous episodes of The hubbin Lab
podcast we discuss supplements while
supplements aren't necessary for
everybody many people derive tremendous
benefit from them for things like
improving sleep for hormone support and
for Focus to see this supplements
discussed on the hubman Lab podcast go
to live momentus spelled o us so it's
Liv mous.com
huberman if you're not already following
me on social media you can do so by
going to huberman lab on all social
media platforms so that's Instagram
Twitter now called X LinkedIn Facebook
and threads on all of those platforms I
cover science and science related tools
some of which overlaps with the content
of the hubman Lab podcast but much of
which is distinct from the content
covered on the hubman Lab podcast again
that's hubman lab on all social media
platforms if you haven't already
subscribed to our neural network
newsletter the neural network newsletter
is a zero cost monthly newsletter that
includes podcast summaries as well as
toolkits so toolkits for sleep toolkits
for Learning and plasticity toolkits
related to dopamine regulation and much
more again it's all zero cost you simply
go to hubman lab.com go to the menu tab
scroll down to newsletter and simply
enter your email and we do not share
your email with anybody thank you once
again for joining me for today's
discussion about tenacity and willpower
and last but certainly not least thank
you for your interest in
[Music]
science